ladies and gentlemen I wish you all good
morning I'm very welcome to noble forum
for the announcement of this year's
Nobel Prize in Physiology or medicine so
I will first read an announcement in
Swedish followed by English and we will
down present some background to the
price and then open up for questions of
course you Bella fashioning the
Karolinska Institutet or a dog was
lifted at noble
facility eller medicine or tortoise and
or Don Scarlett de la silla came along
James P Alison of task ooh-hoo
for the errors of text or cancer by
handling human Hamling of mm fish for
its bronze mechanism al the Nobel
assembly at Karolinska Institutet has
today decided toward the 2018 Nobel
Prize in Physiology or medicine jointly
to James P Allison and tasko hangzhou
for their discovery of cancer therapy by
inhibition of negative immune regulation
here we see the two new laureates James
P Allison was born in Alice in Texas in
the United States he performed his
prize-winning studies at University of
California Berkeley and at Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center in New
York is now active at the University of
Texas MD Anderson Cancer Center in
Houston tasco hangzhou was born in Kyoto
in Japan he performed his prize-winning
studies at Kyoto University where he
still active I will now leave the word
to Professor Klaus Shara member of the
Nobel Committee who will describe this
year's discovery so please close
ladies and gentlemen let us start by a
summarizing metaphor it is all about
interference with the brakes of our
immune system as a means to unleash this
defense and harness it to develop
treatment of cancer cancer is a common
term for many different diseases caused
by uncontrolled proliferation and
migration of cells eventually cancer
cells can spread to distant organs so
called metastasis usually leading to
death cancer represents a major medical
challenge in the global perspective
there are three pillars in the treatment
of cancer remove it by surgery
eliminated by radiation or attack it
with drugs that harm the cancer cells
treatment has improved considerably
during the last 50 years more than two
out of three are killed today but note
that these are average figures which
consider major differences between
cancers in different organs between
early and advanced disease and also
between different countries for many
cancers very few patients can be cured
every year many millions of people die
from cancer so noble types of treatment
are desperately needed there has been a
huge investment in basic research with
the aim to acknowledge as a platform for
new therapies one area was of particular
interest can immunity be harnessed to
attack cancer so let us look at our
immune system it protects us from
infections it comprises a great
diversity of cells and molecules with
different functions and they can be
found all over the body a fundamental
property of the system is its ability to
discriminate discriminate between self
and non-self and bacteria can be
attacked
and indeed innovative basic research in
tumor immunology during the last 50
years have revealed the number of ways
whereby cancer cells can also be
recognized as non-self this led to cure
of cancer in many mice and also to
successful treatment of some patients
however it was impossible to develop
efficient generalize generalizable
therapies for clinical practice clearly
an important piece of the puzzle was
missing and this is what our loads this
year have solved now let us take a
closer look at the T cell with the T
appearing here and we focus on it in the
80s scientists have discovered t cell
receptors that bind to structures
recognized as non-self you see the
structure as a dot in purple here these
structures can be picked up from cancer
cells and be presented by so-called
antigen presenting cells these cells
that recognize something foreign with
the receptor as here they get a signal
to act but this is not sufficient to get
them going additional proteins on the
surface of the T cells must also engaged
in the decision acting as accelerator or
gas pedal they were called Co receptors
and the research field around them was
termed co-stimulation
many researchers contributed and
observed that even more molecules were
involved but with quite the opposite
function the instead worked like breaks
and here they are in yellow or at least
one of them in yellow and this one is
called ctla4 a complicated name but
please remember it it will be very
important so when you pull the break it
tells the T cell to hold back stop
Alison was one of the researchers who
observed that this molecule works like a
brake you can see that it interferes
with the accelerator on the T cell now
some research team started to explore
this to treat autoimmunity
but Addison he had an entirely different
ID he had developed an antibody to see
Taylor for shown in green here and if
you block or release the brake with the
green antibody and listen reason the
consequence should be that the t-cells
are Unleashed and become more active and
they should now hopefully attack the
cancer cells this was the hypothesis and
the key experiment was performed in
Alice's laboratory at University of
California Berkeley over the Christmas
in 1994 and the results were spectacular
the mouse who had been treated with the
antibody the yellow curve were cured
from cancer while the control mice
developed large tumors this seminal
study represents the birth of a new
concept for immunotherapy
today often refer to as immune
checkpoint inhibitor the brake acts in
the checkpoint Allison was now eager to
apply it for benefit of patients at
first there was only limited interest
but eventually a small biotech company
took on the challenge to produce the
human antibody the first step on the
long journey a few years later the first
clinical trials were started and one
comprised 14 patients suffering from
metastatic melanoma the pigmented cancer
of the skin this picture shows how
metastatic melanoma can present on the
patient now he started to treat the
patients and some of them showed
striking responses the tumors shrunk
they could even disappear at the
patients showed a more modest or no
response at all and severe side effects
were noted in some patients but the
results were positive enough and this
started a long series of larger trials
conducted by clinical colleagues to cut
a long story short in 2011 the treatment
was approved for inoperable metastatic
Allyson had now established a novel
concept for cancer therapy but several
questions remained could checkpoint
therapy we developed to cure more
patients and could it be generalized to
other types of cancer studies that would
lead in this direction were already
ongoing in a laboratory across the
Pacific in Japan actually they had been
started several years before Alison's
key discovery so we crossed the Pacific
we go to Japan and we go back in time to
the point where Alison had started and
you will remember and recognize the
t-cell receptor and the accelerator
enter our second laureate that gohan you
who 1992 discovered a new protein on
t-cells which he called P D 1 and P D 1
is shown on jello here on the T cells he
did not understand what the molecule was
doing but together with his colleagues
at Kyoto University he launched an
ambitious curiosity driven research
program to understand its function
several years of research later he could
reveal the chain of molecular
interactions leading him to conclude
that pd-1 also acted as a break just as
italy for but in a different manner you
step on the brake and the T cells holds
back in addition on you had identified
the ligand the molecular partner of pd-1
and he found that it was expressed on
antigen presenting cells but also on
cancer cells and now it became
immediately evident to test whether
blockade of pd-1 could also be used to
unleash these responses against cancer
so what happens when you release the
brake like this ho news and other groups
immediately started to gather evidence
for this and here we are looking at one
of the studies of melanoma the skin
cancer and in this case it is spreading
to the liver in mice the control mice on
your
left develop multiple metastases in
their livers while several of the mines
had been treated with the antibody to
your right had almost no metastases at
all in this study on your correctly
predicted that the antibody one
treatment might complement the
antecedent for treatment since the two
worked by a different mechanism he also
predicted that pd-1 might give less side
effects
hanno now also turned to the
pharmaceutical industry an intensive
program started conducted by other
clinical scientists mainly in the u.s.
again similar or even more dramatic
responses were noted not only in
melanoma patients and fda approved the
anti pd-1 treatment for melanoma in 2014
and for line transfer as well as kidney
cancer in 2015 so now we have two
treatments available for patients based
on immune checkpoint and therapy and
today we have even more and it's time I
think to look at some results in
patients these CT scans are from a
patient treated with anti PD one but the
illustrate process is seen also with
anta's Italy for treatment you can see
the tumor log by the red arrow in the
lung note how it has shrunk dramatically
to your right and it's on its way to
disappear at four months after
initiation of the treatment but please
note also what happened shortly after
the treatment had started at two months
in the middle the tumor appears to be
significantly larger than it was from
the beginning but this is not really
growth of the cancer it is due to
swelling caused by the inflammatory
response with many immune cells entering
the tumor and this is called serve the
progression and is observed quite
frequently and it caused confusion
initially since other types of cancer
treatment usually results in an ended in
an immediate response and shrinkage of
the tumor
let us finally look at an example of
compiled results from many patients
these girls represent survival of
treated patients with a certain type of
melanoma and you should note that just a
decade ago most patients with advanced
disease like this would have died
already after two years previous
standard therapies resulted in long-term
survival for few percent or less and it
would have looked like this the curve
compares three groups of patients
treated with checkpoint inhibition the
release of one break seated a forwarding
green release of the other break pretty
one in blue and release of both in
yellow and we can appreciate that both
treatments are working and TPD one in a
higher proportion of patients than
antici today for but please note the
combination for more than 60% of the
patients are still alive of the three
years this is a spectacular advance in
the treatment of a solid metastatic
tumor and we can expect even better
results in the future when these
different checkpoint inhibitors will be
combined with conventional treatments so
in summary Alison's Antonio's
discoveries have added a new leader in
cancer therapy it represents a
completely new principle because unlike
the previous strategies it is not based
on targeting the cancer cells but rather
the brakes the checkpoints of the host
immune system the seminal discoveries by
the two laureates constitutes prepared
ematic shift and the landmark in the
fight against cancer thank you very much
so if we could have the lights a little
brighter here we have some distinguished
experts from the Nobel assembly and the
Nobel Committee dr. Jonas Berg who is an
expert in oncology Ted Smith
from the Nobel Committee dr. Anna
Waddell the chair of the Nobel Committee
and of course Klaus so please if there
are any questions here we have hello my
name is Farah from China's national
Xinhua news agency I've got a question
for the experts so this year's medicine
award is given to the new cancer
treatment so what are the significance
of the so word are we saying that the
cancer treatment has been cancers has
been a huge challenge nowadays for the
human being what are the significance
for this award this year top so this
type of cancer treatment is very
interesting because it works in a
completely new fashion all previous
cancer treatments were essentially
directed against the tumor cell but this
particular treatment is directed against
the immune system and one interesting
aspect is that it works on many
different types of tumors not only on
one particular tumor but on many
different types here we have one custom
yeah can you please wait for the
microphone we okay we'll start with okay
let's go
okay I have a question about you know
James Ellison anti-cat G for therapy I
know that another excellent scientists
are on Yale University leapin Chen he's
also a high highly eligible or Canada
for this you know just order let you
know the reason that he's not been
selected thank you the question was
about another scientist who is not given
this year's award now let me first say
that the devel committee divides the
world of the people of the world in two
groups the ones that have received the
nobel prize in medicine and the ones who
have not yet receive it and we'd love to
comment on the ones who have received it
I prefer to refrain from comments on the
others having said that I would like to
add that as I tried to imply in this
presentation
many scientists contribute is to this
whole field and if you want to read
about the contributions of different
scientists many of them very very smart
and clever who contributed a lot we
refer you to the advanced information
that just I think is now out on the
noble web where you can read about all
the contributions of many other
scientists which were also important at
least to stand out thank you
I'm sufficient access song from green
post and China radio I just like to ask
you that when we talk about this immune
checkpoint therapy is it it means that
doesn't mean that it is a method that
narrow down the point to check for the
cancer treatment or how better is it is
than the previous ones
thank you
the effects of these checkpoint
inhibitors are quite remarkable because
they really define a new concept where
you release the brakes previous types of
immune therapy they were really trying
to make use of the immune system by
stimulating it and enhancing its
capacity but here in that concept you
didn't release the brakes and for that
reason those therapies were not as
successful as these therapies and the
fundamental thing also is that these
therapies as we are discussing today
they are apparently and very nicely
working in previously quite therapy
resistant tumors as mentioned here
malignant melanoma different types of
lung cancer to some extent renal cancers
to give some examples while
quote-unquote simpler cancer which have
been sensitive to endocrine therapy
cytostatics radiotherapy etc the effect
by the conventional therapy has been
quite good but for the tumors I
mentioned that present armamentarium up
until they have not been that fantastic
yeah what what about the side effects
the side effects are there it's correct
but if you compare with other approved
drugs or therapies for cancer there by
all means always side effects and if I
compare their momentary on with the new
drugs we are discussing the checkpoint
inhibitors the side effects are for
almost all patient manageable although
they are in a scale up to five they are
not rare with grade three to four side
effects but mostly of them they are
reversible and it's clearly so if you
look at the benefit namely the effect on
the cancer and then your balance then
versus the risk there is no question
that there is a clearly positive benefit
risk balance for these
for the therapy of the cancers we have
discussed here this is for Nordic
Chinese times I will question for we I
would like to thank you for this to
great scientists but we have now run
thousands for clinical trial with pd-1
and sitio for and with combination
therapy so we even run out of patience
so what's what's the next future or
rational design for this combination
with this kick point therapy thank you
yes I think what's most promising now we
have we have now a completely new tool
to add to the toolbox so it has sort of
revitalized the whole area so to find
the right combination for the right
subgroups and even for the right
patients and go into a more
individualized therapy will be a very
important process there are very many
studies of course ongoing doing that so
there will be more concepts more
checkpoint inhibitors most likely but
combining what we already have also with
conventional therapy there is a huge
benefit to gain there I'm sure you
the powerfulness by combine therapy I
can mention triple negative breast
cancer in a small randomized phase 2
study if you just give chemotherapy and
20% one in five patient that tumor
totally disappeared in the areas which
were there before therapy if you do the
combination of chemotherapy plus a
checkpoint inhibitor in in six out of
ten - after three patients in reality
the tumor disappeared so it was a
dramatically improvement from twenty to
sixty percent in this very early study
demonstrating that combination for some
patient could be quite useful using the
conventional therapy strategies we saw
earlier photo of you speaking on the
phone to the winners could you tell us a
little bit how they reacted when they
heard the news that they were this
year's winners dr hangzhou sounded
extremely pleased a little bit difficult
time to guess if we had some expectancy
of this news but he seemed rather
surprised he expressed very clearly how
satisfied he was also sharing the prize
are there any other questions I think
then if there is no one else want to ask
anything that we can conclude this press
conference and there are some of you who
asked for interviews so we will try and
satisfy
all requests as quickly as we can so
thank you very much for coming thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
I was wise
professor class seller member of the
bail committee we have just heard that
this is this year you are awarding the
discovery of checkpoint inhibitors could
you please explain what this is well
first of all this is a treatment against
cancer and it's a new principle for
treatment because unlike previous
treatments where you target the cancer
cell this treatment targets the hosts
immune system the patient's immune
system and it does so by releasing or
blocking the brakes of the immune system
and when you release the brakes please
go faster and we have a strong response
against the patient's cancer cells the
laureates name's James Ellison he has
been mentioned there for a quite a while
how come with this you are awarded time
is ripe the first approved the drug
based on these treatments it came in
2011 patients have been treated for
several years now and we can see the
long term outcome and it's very
convincing and we possibly really big
step in the fight against cancer it was
quite complicated different cells and
different receptors but in order to
describe this price in an accessible way
what kind of metaphor would you use I
would like to use the break metaphor the
brake pedal that you have in a car for
example where you can step on it and
everything stops
sit and you get things going this is a
new one kind of cancer treatment what
cancer patients can be treated using
this method are there any limits but the
most dramatic responses are seen with
the particular type of skin cancer
malignant melanoma I'm sure most viewers
know what it is it's a pigmented cancer
on the skin other cancers that respond
with at least a PD one treatment or nine
cancer and kidney cancer and lymphoma
and many other cancers actually also so
it will be very exciting to see in the
future exactly how broad how broadly
this can be applied personally what
makes you enthusiastic by this price I
myself am an immunologist and I have
actually interesting new discoveries in
tumor immunology where we reveal basic
mechanisms but they were never
sufficient to be able to cure cancer in
patients they were sufficient to cure
cancer in mice which is somewhat easier
and all the other previous attempts to
boost immune system such as vaccination
or giving cells they worked in some
patients but you could never generalize
it to many patients and this is what is
different about this one and it makes a
big difference for certain patients some
patients survive and are killed and some
patients get four years rather than one
year and that is quite amazing
no he turned to the laureates in James
Ellison and tasuku Pandu who are they I
have met them but I don't know either of
them very well but the professor allison
is a basic immunology sort trained in
medicine but in biology from the
beginning he became interested already
when he was a small boy and his father
came in as a chemistry kid and yes at
the standard career in basic immunology
he made many important discoveries
before this one and he has been in many
different centers in the United States
Berkeley was mentioned here but he has
also been at the Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center in New
York and in MD Anderson in Texas where
he is now I'm also told that he plays
the harmonica in a blow span because the
segments the professor homeo is also
very distinguished the basic immunology
see section an MD so it says medicine
cranium but he has also contributed very
important discoveries in basic
immunology before this one and he was
not in cancer immunology from the
beginning
similar to demon is a new supporting
cast immunology but this basic
scientists made the discoveries and
persistently followed them through and
developed this fantastic treatment stem
I'm not sure whether a professor from
your place an instrument but I know that
he plays good and is very interested in
office when they were doing this
discovery whether looking for this or
was it a surprise for them when they
for professor Allison I think he was
working with the basic regulation of the
immune system like many others and he
did not discover the molecule that he
was working but he realized its
potential so he rapidly tested an ID
that nobody else tested
I don't know how expected it was for him
to get into cancer but he did because
Vanya I'm sure he did not think of
cancer at all in the beginning when he
looked and found his molecules he was
two completely different things and
actually probably had ideas that it was
doing something completely different but
as he went on and he gradually revealed
how this miracle world
he understood with inspiration for
medicine how this one could add even
more efficiently and finally if you were
to do an elevator pitch on this price
with the goal to simply convey the
overall concept in an exciting way what
would you say them these scientists have
discovered how you can lock the brakes
of the immune system so that it goes
much faster and act in a much more
intensive way and thus can attack cancer
cells so we can kill cancer with
you